so hello everybody I like to introduce
you to my brother Matthew and some of
you might have seen Matthew we did a
conversation with Jordan Peterson all
three of us discussing the story of
Abraham and so Matthew and I we're used
to speaking we're used to talking about
symbolism together we've been talking
about it for me since we were teenagers
and so we decided that we're going to
try to have these discs on verse a
Chinon line to talk about what symbolism
is you know what are the categories and
and what are the criteria for a proper
symbolic interpretation of a story um
but hopefully we'll be able to do it
because we have our own shortcuts in our
own way of talking about things so we're
going to make a big effort to to be
comprehensible to everybody so so here
we go so so now I even have to use your
name in English I'm used to speaking to
you in French that's not easy alright so
so I'll call you met you because I can't
say Matthew it's not possible all right
so I met you one of the things that one
of the things I want to start with is so
I've been getting a lot of the comments
that I'm getting about about symbolism
and a diggities comments keep keep
coming back and I try to address a
little bit in my my video about about
simple its symbolic versus literal
interpretation but people seem to really
want to oppose those two things they
really want to oppose this idea of like
a factual literal world and then a world
of meaning but for both of us in our in
our discussions it seems like that is
just not how it works maybe we can start
by giving us your your vision of that
and we can start the discussion that way
yeah well I think that's one of the
major problems with people in symbolism
today is that we understand the world in
a completely different way as it used to
be understood and it's such a
fundamental difference that trying to
understand the world and it truly
symbolic wave requires such a
a transformation of your of your of your
mind of your presupposition it's a
really hard pill to swallow to be able
to understand symbolism in a way that
won't force you to make a distinction
between meaning and fact so if you if
you're used to thinking in a
materialistic way which we all are
everyone's a materialist today in my
opinion because science is completely
dominated everything so it's helped us
to understand a lot of things but it's
also hindered us to understand other
things in completely different fields of
things so so basically if we want to
recapture what symbolism really is we
have to go way back and think of the
universe in completely different terms
as we do today so basically the way we
understand things today is we interpret
everything everything in terms of matter
and energy basically instructor so
that's how everything's understood the
only causality left today is a sort of
mechanical causality where there's a
transfer of energy or transfer of matter
or so it's a mechanistic way of
understanding reality so if you
understand reality like that you can't
really understand symbolism the way it
was the way it was understood in the
past and the way it's described in the
Bible yeah I mean I think one of the
ways that I've been trying to to help
people to see symbolism again is to try
to get people to dive back and in their
experience to to kind of go back to the
lived experience let's say so the way
that you encounter a tree is not the
same you don't encounter a tree in the
same category that a scientist would
analyze a tree or the way you encounter
you know the heavens or the way you
encounter earth they're not the same
categories and so trying to get people
to to to
to go back to categories and the
craziest thing is that those the
symbolic categories are really there
they're at the base of our of our
existence and they're still there even
if they're still there today right yet
if we pretend that they're not like you
know categories like high and low you
know you know even even things like hot
and cold like hot and cold are not
scientific categories they're categories
of experiences so these these basic
categories of experience to hire our
keys they're still and they still have
exactly the same meaning as they used to
it's all still there but we don't
interpret it in the right way to make it
significant enough to pay attention to
it yes one of one of the ways that that
that you've talked about that you talked
about about to me before and you've even
written about in some of your texts is
this idea of at least for a moment at
least for let's say the the experience
to try to get a sense of how things come
together and have meaning is to - for
for a specific moment to shut down to
try to shut down the the let's say the
the quantitative you know scientific way
of approaching the world and also so I
mean and it's the craziest thing is it's
not that that hard to do I remember
because we we still think in the other
way right a lot of in a lot of ways I
remember hearing recently a podcast with
some Harrison and he was talking about
he said said something like when you
drink water it doesn't matter what you
think you're always drinking h2o I'm
like that's not true no one drinks h2o
we drink wet we drink cold we drink warm
we drink you know flavor crashing
there's nothing to do with I mean did
not not not completely nothing to do but
the category of of - you know hydrogen
and in it is like it's not it's that's
not the same as as the categories of
experience yeah yeah
so the only problem with that I guess is
that people will think that it makes it
arbitrary which which it doesn't
because they're still universal
experiences that all humans have
it doesn't mean it because it's it's
some interpreted through the lens of our
consciousness it does it mean that it's
arbitrary in the sense that every
anybody could say whatever they want to
interpret it however they want yeah so
that's the only problem with the idea of
bringing it back to your experience I
agree with that's what people have to do
but they have to keep in mind that the
human experience is a universal
experience some things are universal in
the human experience we all eat we all
sleep we all work we all read etc etc so
the human experience is not random or
they're arbitrary it's universal and in
a way it's funny because to get to true
symbolism you almost have to go you
almost have to destroy what people
usually think what it is to give meaning
to something like you have to go beyond
the emotional or personal you know a
version of what happens and then go back
to the really basic basic ground level
kind of almost you know primed
primordial theory X or something it's
like so so the grass the experience of
the grass isn't that isn't like that you
know that that nice Saturday that you
spent with your family and now the grass
for you reminds you of that that nice
moment that you spent you know the
reality of grass has more to do with the
fact that it's below your feet that it's
it's down there you know that it you
know that it's it's all these it's like
a chaotic mix of different things that
are just there at the on the on the
surface of the earth rather than you
know that but maybe that participates in
the reason why laying in the grass on
that nice Saturday was a pleasant
experience problem it does actually but
you have to go beyond that little that
like psychological literary type of
interpretation to get to the baser
reality yeah just because it's
interpreted through human consciousness
doesn't mean that it's like a personal
individual interpretation it can be but
those that's not how symbolism works
because I don't care about some person's
individual interpretation of something
when it when that interpretation is
based on nothing but their little ideas
symbolism becomes important when the
interpretation is universal I mean
that's one of the criterias which by
which we can distinguish real symbolism
from the kind of symbolism you can find
in a movie or or in a story that that's
just been made up by someone on the
street and even then most of the time
when people tell a story or write a
movie they will use universal symbol
because otherwise nobody would care
exactly so even when it is interpreted
through individuals if they want people
to care about their their interpretation
of reality they'll make it Universal
otherwise nobody cares right and that's
so in a way the idea would be to say
that symbolism is really it's really the
way that our our consciousness is
written in a way it's like it's what
it's what could what makes us what makes
it possible for us to even perceive and
engage the world is these basic
structures that are that are that were
made out of you know that are that our
experience is made out of I mean that's
symbolism it's really very I mean it's
really at the base it's really what
makes us what makes it possible for us
to engage with the world that's the same
the same structure as the religious the
religious hierarchy like the religious
symbolism yes
so yeah in fact the basic structures of
symbolism are so Universal that even
people who would like to deny them are
are into those structures they can't
escape it so like a scientist let's say
even an atheist he's working on a
scientific discovery or something like
that he's trying to perform an
experiment he can't escape the basic
structures of symbolism so so what is
this person
doing he's trying to unite a theory that
he has an abstract theory a metaphysical
idea he's trying to join that with the
facts that he observed so that this
scientist is he's a human between heaven
and earth trying to mediate between
heaven and earth he's trying to mediate
his abstract theory with a concrete fact
so the scientist whether he likes it or
not is participating in the symbolic
worldview
he's a mediator between heaven and earth
whether he likes it or not and when I
say I talked about this was when I went
talked to Jordan Pederson when I say
have an I mean meaning so theoretical
meaning and when I say earth I mean the
factual reality concrete reality and
that's what it means in the Bible and
that means in in pretty much all
traditions so yeah and I totally because
I made I made recently I made that video
about how science is nested in religion
trying to talk a little bit about that
as well and and it was funny because
just what is it like a few a few like a
week later I heard I heard I hate always
harping on sam Harris but I heard I
heard Sam Harris speaking about the
phenomenon of emergence and he was
talking about how we see these different
these different patterns appear at
different scales of reality and how you
know like let's say the same patterns
appear at a biological level that as a
city and he was trying to like he was
really struggling to to make those jumps
those qualitative jumps between you know
quarks and atoms to you know a person to
a city until any any youth he kept using
the world higher-order phenomena he kept
using this hierarchical language about
these higher orders of manifestations
and I thought wow man you're sure you're
a religious thinker you don't don't even
know it yeah and I think I I listen to
that also and I think the answer was
also in
because what the person said is you
don't want to explain higher levels of
phenomenon with the lower levels because
it's extremely complex
that's not go complex so summer has been
like that answer okay I don't know but
if other the outside is that I'll go
ahead keep going yeah so it's so
extremely complex that giving an
explanation as that order would probably
be impossible and even if it is it would
be coherent to us as humans you see so
right there it's important you can't get
away from it you can't get away from the
fact that we are humans we are observing
phenomenon we can't extract ourselves
from the equation of knowledge so the
scientists the materials tries to step
away from the universe and look at it as
if he's not in it yeah and which is fine
to a certain degree it's fine to
understand such certain things like
mechanical causality the perfect way to
do that is to distract yourself from
from reality but you still can't escape
the other reality which is the ancient
way of thinking where it's centered on
on the human it's centered
unconsciousness and so basically the
scientists can try to create a worldview
in which he's not there and in which his
theories don't exist then that model of
the universe but it's problematic for
certain things it's problematic so it's
also probably problematic to included so
there's a reason why science has
discovered materialistic science has
discovered a whole bunch of things that
the traditional worldview hasn't
discovered yeah because it's useful to
get out of the system but so ideally I
think it reaches a limit that's so
important region hits me I think it has
any set limit I think I think quantum
physics is one of the signs that this
limit has been reached because they
reached a point where the observer can't
can't get out of the equation
so you have to admit as an observer that
when you look at the phenomenon you
you are impacting the phenomenon there's
no way out now there's no way out yeah
so they have reached that limit and so
it's going to come to them soon they're
going to have to deal with that limit I
don't I don't think they're dealing with
it I think they're going to have to deal
with it though I mean what does it mean
yeah it seems like there was a whole
bunch of things that happened at the mid
at the mid maybe like post war period
that because it was not it wasn't just
that observation but it was also good as
good as your own completeness theorem
yeah it's a theory
same problem right and then and then
Heidegger I think I think Heidegger was
part of that and just Heidegger
presenting the idea of presenting this
idea that you the way that being
presents itself to us like I was saying
at the beginning the way that we
encounter the world as as consciousness
is not the same as the as the technical
it's a kind of scientific way of viewing
the world in it you cannot you can't
discount the other completely you just
just can't because then you don't know
how to act in the world and so seems
like he's like maybe it's taking a while
for people to kind of come to the as a
finality of what that's going to give
but I mean hopefully this is this is it
this is happening right now that people
are going to start and I think that one
of the things that Jordan Peterson seems
to be doing is tapping into that
uneasiness that people have about seeing
the limits of science but then coming at
it from a scientific point of view and
trying to to help people see it without
completely without without because
people without becoming insane get it up
without becoming it seriously because
you can if you if you delve too much
into this kind of universe of self
referential contradiction you you can go
insane so you can lose everything so the
idea is not to I mean my interest in
traditional cosmology doesn't come as a
cost of scientific knowledge and other
thing and not at all they're not opposed
they are but they shouldn't be they
should they should team up it possible
so but what
the things the people who are
materialists have to understand is that
is going to eventually happen is that
traditional cosmology should not be
interpreted in terms of materialism
right because when you do that it's
ridiculous so they're right but when
they laugh at religion when they laugh
at the religious worldview in the
traditional worldview they find it
ridiculous they're right because the
reason is they're trying to look at it
with their own lens their own
materialism they're trying to look at
something that's fundamentally not
materialistic so yes it doesn't work
it's ridiculous but the worst part of
that is that is that it's not just is
not just the the atheists that are doing
that they're reacting to religious
people doing that yeah exactly yeah and
then interpreting the religious because
of the traditional cosmologies with
their materialist point of view and then
saying absolutely ridiculous things in
doing so and so yes
so the Atheist has every reason to mock
them except it's a desert or desert but
I have zero animosity toward or 80s I
have German animosity towards skeptics
because they're not they're not
responding to religion really they're
responding they're answering to the
problem of people who are essentially
materialist and don't know it and
interpret the Bible for example with
materialism and even though it doesn't
work they still stick to it so so I
think you gave an example in one of your
videos I'm not sure which one but yet an
example of stuff you asked somebody what
does it mean when he says he went up
into heaven gentle let's say for example
Elijah goes up and dad what does that
mean does it mean that he goes up into
the atmosphere and then into outer space
or something like that if it becomes
ridiculous immediately so there has to
be a stage where people who are
scientifically minded stop interpreting
a look like that okay don't worry about
what certain religious people safe
if they interpret it like that it's not
it that's not what has to be critiqued
that's simply wrong what has to happen
is we have to read understand what it
means to go up into heaven failure
that's just an example
pretty much everything has to be in a
wave reinterpreted according to a
cosmology that allows it and that
cosmology is is the one I was describing
it with Jordan Pederson it it's a man is
a mediator between heaven and earth and
that's how things have to be interpreted
in the Bible so when it says go up into
heaven you have to interpret it like
that it was heaven has that meaning it
doesn't mean the atmosphere does it mean
that so that doesn't mean the atmosphere
at the same level that when when Samara
says higher level phenomena it means
that one phenomena is stacked on top of
the other if you can't you can't use the
language of hierarchy to describe these
higher levels of manifestation and then
Mock the idea of oh you're silly sky God
in heaven it's like that you're using
the same word they're using exactly the
same language yes in the same structure
but you're mocking mine yes but that's
the thing they're not mocking your
structure they're mocking the people
yeah who still insist on interpreting it
in a in a materialistic way as in the
way the way we were just laughing at it
means going up into the atmosphere so
they are not mocking that they are
mocking the people who still interpret
it in a way that doesn't make sense if
we can make people understand what it
means then I don't think there's going
to be as much discrepancy between
science and traditional cosmology in
fact I think there's none yeah because
they're not talking about the same thing
hardly ever and what's interesting is
what I found in kind of my own research
is what one of the difficulties that
people have is that when you read
medieval writings and when you read
let's say the ancient it's difficult for
people to understand because those
medieval those medieval writers were not
comparing themselves to some
that didn't exist yet like they weren't
comparing their discourse to a
scientific discourse because that the
scientific discourse just wasn't part of
their world and so they just speak
forthrightly and now when we look at it
with our own lens we see it just seems
to be absolute gibberish it doesn't make
any sense or what's interesting is that
in the transition you can catch like in
the transition between the traditional
worldview and and the modern world view
you can catch glimpses of people saying
oh wait a minute no no no don't don't
don't think this is like the same way
that you're you're like you know hitting
a hammer on a piece of wood so like in
Dante for example there's places where
he actually says he talked about
ascending into heaven and and you know
encountering the encountering higher
spirits in the different heavenly
spheres and then he says he says no the
spirits don't actually inhabit two
heavenly sphere atmospheres
it's a condescension of the heavenly
language for us to be able to understand
a higher truth that we we speak about it
in those terms as like well you know and
she was right at the transition before
like the scientific the scientific
revolution and so he was already seeing
that people were changing the ways of
thinking and he was trying to prevent
them from getting having like a science
fiction version of like a Marvel Comics
version of spirituality like the gods
live another planet yes because that's
what happened that's actually a good
point because that's exactly what
happens if you don't make the proper
language shift because the word shift I
mean if you're if you're naive you don't
realize that the meaning of words shifts
constantly so if like like what you're
saying before water is h2o it might be
that today but it's extremely naive to
think that in the time of the Bible for
example when when the book of Genesis
was written that that's what water meant
it did it meant something else it meant
it meant something I had nothing to do
with any chemical composition or
anything like that so we always have to
be aware that word shift so for example
I mean and the
a natural way that word [ __ ] word shift
when your knowledge of the universe
increases so if you say for example
earth means matter okay so that's what
it used to mean and there's a reason why
it meant that because all matter came
from the land from the earth okay so
when your your your knowledge of the
universe expands then you realize that
there's matter that's not in the soil in
the earth so then you have to expand
your category right so now you invent
you use the word matters that our earth
let's say
so now you've separated those two
categories but they weren't separate
before when all things came from the
earth then there was a coincidence
between the metaphysical category called
matter and the concrete reality that we
call the soil the earth but when your
knowledge expanding the word [ __ ] but if
you don't keep up with that shift of
language then you start to say things
that don't make sense and then it's
things look ridiculous
no because and and it's funny because
it's like people who criticize the
religious worldview or criticize the
ancient ancient vision of the world it's
like either you really have to think
that everybody was on drugs or something
that's what you would have to think
because it's so disconnected to the
materialist way of interpreting the
world that it's like either they were
completely delusional and lived in like
a losing a world or maybe they were as
smart as you or they just were talking
about things at a different way yeah I I
prefer the second because it's more
generous and more and ended actually and
when you explore that direction you find
an amazing that's where you find amazing
things you find that's where you can
discover the the pearls that are hidden
in the ancient texts or else you know
you read you read to read stories and it
just seems like it's just a bunch of not
yet and that and that's how it is
interpreted and so their right to their
right to market so they ask there has to
be an effort
to understand what the ancient language
was at some point you can't just assume
that you know automatically what things
what words refer to I mean the example I
always use when I talk about these
things is the example of the fish I
always use that example because I think
it's an easy one to understand so I
remember when I was when I was a kid
there was this Sunday school teacher who
said something like he was talking about
the story of Jonah and I don't remember
what that person was but that person
said well we know that Jonah wasn't
swallowed by a whale because the text
says it's a fish and whales aren't our
fish okay so and I was I was pretty
young at that time I don't remember
exactly maybe eight years old or
something
and even then I knew there was something
wrong with that I knew that didn't make
any sense to think that you can use a
modern definition of a fish and apply it
to a story that's thousands of years old
I mean obviously when when people talk
about a fish it didn't mean the same the
same as what it means today like today a
prerequisite to be called a fish and
they got that Gill
I think the animal has to have guilt but
obviously that's not what it used to
mean fish were things that lived in the
water and that's about is probably that
was the definition of a fish and it
wasn't a wrong definition it was an
incomplete different it was just a
different definition of fish the word
shifted and now the word fish means
something else so we have to be careful
not to use modern interpretation of
words to interpret ancient story this is
very naive it was it was it was
something it was a definition like we
still have definitions like that like I
I use the words like I use the word
grass before that's a perfect definition
which is similar to the definition of
fish who just underwater I mean if you
if you took the time to analyze all the
different types of botanical species
that are that are on the ground that you
call grass you think like you're an
idiot to say that that they're all the
same of course they're completely
different in term
of their their species and their their
their different origins but the that
category grass is a perfectly fine
category of human engagement so it's
like yeah I mow the grass
I don't mow like all these different
enumerate for you all the different
types of plants that I'm mowing when I'm
mowing the grass it's like it's the
grass that's fly again and and it's the
word that that refers to the human
experience so that's a good example we
don't care about the scientific
definition of what grass is like we
don't care what it's composed of really
we don't we care about the fact that
it's in our backyard it makes it look
nice or something like that but anyway
the idea is we have to be careful not to
interpret ancient ancient stories with
modern categories and I keep repeating
that because that's what 90% of the
people who miss read traditional stories
and physical stories do there so it
solves about 90% of the problem that
people have when when they rate at it so
when you at least try to find a proper
meaning for the categories already the
problem of the distinction between the
symbolic interpretation and a literal
interpretation usually vanishes it
usually vanishes right there if you if
you try to find the proper meaning of
words that dichotomy is usually enough
to make it completely disappear so one
of the examples I use I use in my mind
for that to show that is you say for
example in the Bible the snakes in the
garden okay if I say that's a symbol of
time the snake in the garden is a symbol
of time let's say okay so if you have a
modern scientific definition of time
that makes no sense it looks like I'm
just arbitrarily assigning a meaning to
that element of the story it looks like
I'm just making it up basically
but if you have a proper definition of
time which fits with with an ancient
understanding then it does work it
doesn't it's not arbitrary anymore
because if you say for example that time
used to be understood in a way where it
meant the cause of transformation or an
influence of transformation something
like that that's what time is change
that's not that's not changed yeah
there's because all this change if the
influence of change has change itself
something like that it's not what
scientists call time today
what business is called time has nothing
to do with what we just said and it
becomes just an empty quantity used to
describe a mechanistic world in terms of
times and event events in time and space
it's not the cause of change it's not an
influence of change it's a timing in the
in the modern way time it's not seen as
a cause of change but it certainly was
seen as that in the ancient world time
was cyclical transformation like a
powerful influence that transformed
things changing them into their offices
actually changing the light into
darkness darkness into light life and
death that was time so that definition
of time if you use that then you can say
the snake in the story of the garden is
a symbol of time right no matter for
yeah there's no matter we it is the
cause of transformation in that story
where's the metaphor it vanished just
because I use the right definition of
the concept of time and I stopped using
the scientific mechanistic one all of a
sudden when I say symbol it doesn't mean
metaphor anymore it doesn't mean an
allegory it means nothing of the sort
this snake is a cause of transformation
in this story it is a symbol of time
yeah and what like what for example and
what it like I like I kind of like you
know this usually is not my usual way of
going about understanding symbolism but
for people who were kind of coming at it
from
outside the way the Jordan the way the
Jordan Petersons kind of traces that
that idea that the snake is like a
symbol of time let's say is a good way
for people to kind of understand it in
the sense that if you're a community
let's say and and there's a predator
that arise you know a predator that
comes from the from comes into your camp
that is that exactly a perfect that's
that's the most archetypal image of
change is then who is a threat that
comes from the the outside the threat
it's both a threat but it's also it can
also be a kind of seduction like it
could be either way like it could be
either a threat or a fascination or or
something that appears from your corner
of your eye and that thing is going to
is going to tumble is going to make
things tumble it's going to make things
move yeah you can potentially change
yeah transform things like if it bites
you it will definitely transform hit
your life into debt so set so in that
sense symbols are not are not metaphors
they're not there and there's certainly
not arbitrary metaphor there's certainly
not conventional agreements on meaning
yeah I think that's really I think
that's really if we can get something
out of this conversation today I think
that's really one of the biggest things
that is an obstacle for people to
understand symbolism is that people
constantly think that symbolism is
something which is added on to literal
facts and that for example like we both
grew up in Protestants in the Protestant
world and in it not everybody but for a
lot of people we grew up with it was
almost as if the idea that something was
had a symbolic meaning was almost like a
threat to the integrity of the of the
thing itself it was always like that
like it was going to swallow up the
factuality of the thing whereas that is
not that's not how it works it is the
very very reason why that's part of the
story means that it's symbolic it has to
be or else how would why would you care
about it why would it depart why would
it be set up in this pattern story yeah
well actually unfortunately it's kind of
a vicious cycle because
when all you have left is in a story
like the Bible in story biblical story
is the fact then you want to defend that
if you're a Christian let's say when
there's no more meaning that's what I
mean it's a vicious cycle because when
you have the meaning you're more
interested in the meaning than the fact
really that's what informs you that's
what shows us how things work that's
what shows you how reality works and it
gives you guidance as what I do in this
situation if the text has meaning it
helps you understand the nature of
reality that's actually what it's really
supposed to help you with but if you
don't have that anymore and you only
think that the text is the description
of an event without meaning then if you
want to remain a Christian you're going
to guard that with your life yeah that's
a letter doing so lastly the last
remnant of your identity is it happens
you've got proof then it happened
you've got to show that it happened and
you don't care I don't care about the
meanie I just care that it happens well
that's a mistake because the real way to
understand the the Bible is through a
traditional cosmology it's the events
that are described in the Bible are
embodiment of metaphysical truth they're
embodiment of cosmic truth they're
embodiments of social truth their
environments of individual troops so at
different scales of reality of our
experience there are calm constant
truths so these are the truth that the
Bible are trying to communicate and it's
unfortunate that it's been lost to to a
great degree but there's work to be done
it's work to be done we have to do that
work of reclaiming the meaning of of
these things just doggedly defending the
factuality of a historian is pointless
it doesn't do anything it doesn't help
because it's the fact contains the
meaning but it's the treasure is in the
meaning it's not in the end than the
fact so the whole point is a
is to support and Express and help us
understand higher meaning spiritual
meanings just like a scientist who
performs an experiment it's not the
experiments that that has value in
itself it's the general truth that the
experiment reveals so I mean it's
interesting I always find fascinating
the story of Galileo that drops to two
cannonballs under the Tower of Pisa okay
I like that story because it's a perfect
example of this dichotomy of meaning and
in fact so in that story why do we keep
retelling that story do we really care
if it happened or not I mean it will be
interesting to think that it happened
but the reason why we keep restating
that story is because that specific
event expresses proves benefit a cosmic
truth which is gravity which is the
nature of gravity so why do we care
about that event the dropping of those
two cannonballs at the same time from
the tower is because it proves a cosmic
truth Deborah yeah the same can be said
about what's in the Bible and who the
event of them dropping the two
cannonball I mean some people say that
it actually happened I've seen other
people say that it doesn't happen and
what I say in my mind is I don't care I
don't care that as much if it happened I
care a lot more that it reveals the
nature of gravity right okay and also I
think that even when we use the word
fact when we talk about a story we
especially if we talk about ancient
stories the the the notion of what a
fact would be in a story that's been I
was told three thousand years ago is not
is where it doesn't mean a scientific
fact right is it that one of the things
that I've been trying to get people to
see is that to remember something and to
attend to something for thousands of
years means that whatever it is that
happened whatever event that happened
has to be compressed like
has to be it has to be brought into
something that that has meaning for
everyone so like I kept thinking about
you know like the idea let's say that
you know let's say that I did I tell the
story of a modern story to an ancient
person and in that story the person has
a has a gun in it and that other person
doesn't understand what the gun a gun is
but I can still tell the story I just
reduce it and I use the word weapon
let's say yeah and then I kind of words
and then maybe the word weapon in his
language means a lance and then finally
it ends up being a lance but it doesn't
matter it's the same you're still
telling this story compressing the
categories in a manner which makes the
universal it doesn't have to be it
doesn't have to be forensic ly the same
thing for it to have for it to be a fact
and for it because categories can be
enlarged and detailed and can be
compressed into more and more compressed
categories and you guess and that is
important to understand because one of
the one of the reasons why the texts are
written the way they are is because they
focus on the meaning so I mean we don't
have the event like let's say we're
talking about the story of Abraham we
don't have the events anymore we only
have a story about the events so the
story was was recounted in a certain way
and the way it was recounted the purpose
of it was so that we understand what is
the meaning yeah exactly yeah and Henry
and we see that I was thinking about
that the other day I was thinking about
kind of trying to find examples of that
for people to to understand and what one
of the things I kept coming coming back
to is the idea of crossing a body of
water and you know like we have in the
Bible we have the flood then we have the
crossing of the Red Sea but then I was
like okay let's keep going and then it's
like oh that's funny because we have
Caesar crossing the Rubicon then we have
Constantine winning winning his bringing
becoming Emperor by fighting a battle on
a bridge and then we have there's all
these examples then you come up to
Washington Crossing the Delaware it's
like why is it that all these
stories of a change of power happen at
the crossing of water in over what a
body of water and then some some some
cynic 200 years from now would say oh
well would Washington that has lots of
Delaware you know because of course you
didn't it's mythological I can see that
it's the same structure as Moses and and
all these other mythological structures
and like no man that's how reality works
we remember that event because that
event in those series of events is the
most conducive to bringing about the
universal meaning that's in that story
like that's how we remembered it yeah
it doesn't mean it's not because
something has a cosmic meaning that that
it didn't happen it's ridiculous to
think that well that doesn't that
doesn't take away from the possibility
that some traditional stories are
fictional that that's what people have
to understand as well I mean it doesn't
mean that every story is factual either
but what's problematic is this dichotomy
this
impossibility of accepting the
coexistence of a fact and a higher
meaning a general universal meaning that
was problematic so it's it's what's
happening in a lot of cases is a lot of
the Christians are defending a
materialistic worldview when they do
that I don't know I don't think they
realize but when they they get annoyed
by a symbolic interpretation of the
Bible they're essentially defending
their enemy basically they're defending
a scientific mechanistic world view
because that's how they think that makes
them might not be aware of it but so a
lot of people a lot of religious people
not just Christians but I mean a lot of
religious people are essentially
materials yeah and it's but they they
believe in God they happen to believe in
God but there's still material it was
every other way in every other way and
the material is about two sides and it's
interesting in terms of meaning because
what you haven't
you meet you meet like conservative type
Christians and their literal like their
their real material is in the sense that
they'd read the Bible and they see it as
like what's written there that's what
happened in the same way that I you know
ate my my muffin this morning and you
know and I mean I cut my moustache like
the same level like the same level then
you meet liberal Christians were like oh
you know like whatever would happen to
Biola none of that happened you know
it's all these stories and then they so
like and the other side of the coin and
then those liberal types they then they
feel like that it's there now that they
can interpret it in whatever way they
want because it doesn't really matter
anyway so then they come up with crazy
interpretation then the conservative
Christians they go crazy because they're
like yeah well in Iraq if we agree that
there's meaning in these if there's
symbolism in these stories look at them
we don't want to be like them we don't
want to be these these crazy pollutant
people and the other people on the top
on the under under like liberal side
they're looking at the Conservatives and
thinking what a bunch of morons like
they really think that there's a snake
on you know we're like in an apple and
and then like two naked people like what
a bunch of idiots so it's like there's
just crazy sides of the same coin
they're just two sides of the same coin
like it's a detachment it's that's the
idea symbolism is the union of fact and
meaning so both if you if you lose that
Union if you use the possibility of a
union like that then yes you either fly
up into heaven you lose your money
interpret it however the Accu want and
it doesn't matter
there's no reason or right to it it's
just anything goes or you just refuse
completely to have any kind of meaning
you just stick to the facts oh one of
them keeps the fact and the other one
keeps the meaning West goes a little bit
crazy because when you get detached from
facts your ideas your theories about
what things link and go fly off in any
direction but if you remain attached to
a fact it limits what you can say about
it it limits the meaning that that you
can can give it yeah one of the one of
the theories that I've had for like the
modern age is that it's been it's been
like Adi Incarnation like it's it's
taken it's been like a taking the idea
of like this
the human and divine nature of Christ
and like ripping them apart and creating
these two these two these two like wild
opposites because we often see modernism
in terms of materialism and everything
but there's a whole other like a cultist
occultic like the occultism and and
new-age and and all these kind of
spiritists type movements that are the
the counterweight of the more kind of
scientific materialism that's there and
those two things develop at the same
time like dick at an indie council
developing his mechanical scientific
things and then you spend the rest of
the most of his life like searching for
the rosie cross like looking for some
esoteric you know invisible society yeah
something that yes that's detached from
reality and basically that's not
concrete well that's just ironic about
all this healthy stuff is the people who
are preserving the true spirit of
traditional thought are scientists
because they care about the union of
meaning in fact yeah they care about the
fact as much as they care about the
theory they don't just want theories
they don't just want fast they want true
knowledge is joining meaning in fact
together theory in fact so like a
universal theory and with particular
facts that's what that's their job
they're still doing that so they're
preserving that spirit in Texas
completely ironic the scientists are the
ones who are the most um good at
preserving the Union that we're supposed
to be preserving as religious people so
it's a little bit ironic but at the same
time it's kind of their fault that we
lost it yeah at the same time because
their materialist so they don't view the
theory as something real they view it as
completely artificial and that well it
could it could be argued that that's
their problem their main problem is they
you met the fact the matter is real but
they don't view the theory that they're
using to interpret the facts as real
yeah why is it not
it's not material perhaps what why this
life is not real there you go because
they're materials it is something is not
material they assume that it has no
reality whatsoever but it's the same way
of thinking that because and they use
mass like they use a method massive it's
real you know it's a kind of a real it's
not a material yes mathematical
structures patterns are real they're not
real in the sense that they are physical
but that's stupid
they're real in the sense that they are
universal they're actually more real
than the individual facts I mean a
mathematical pattern has more reality as
more universality as more applications
implications than any fact I could find
yeah why is it not real that's real it's
more real than real and and the
hierarchy of value is the same thing
because you can't they can't avoid it
like they even though when they're doing
their hardcore sides they try to avoid
it you know when they're even justifying
why we you would study something rather
than study something else they have to
put it in the hierarchy of values
there's no way of avoiding it you can't
you can't get around it yeah it's one of
those structures like mathematics it's
one of those structures that are so real
that there's no way out of it you can
you can't get out of it even by denying
it you're probably going to enter into
that framework of a meaning so so one of
the things that I think is a big deal is
that I mean I've had people who have
written me who are interested in
symbolism and what happens the problem
that happens when people start to
discover symbolism is that not always
but often they kind of go insane if you
go crazy they start seeing when they
start seeing connections between things
as if some strange valve is opened up in
their mind and it's like they believe
like water drank a gallon of wine and
it's like well everything is connected
and then they they write these long as
I've gotten these long emails of people
who like just connect things together
and it is completely crazy and
one of the reasons why rational people
don't want to have anything to do with
symbolism but a lot of people end up
making all kinds of weird connections
and it's clearly irrational ways based
on largely own personal experience and
that's what they want to avoid which I
understand so the idea is like the what
so let's talk about this what could what
could we say are some of the criteria by
which we know that something is has
meaning by which we know something is
worth attending to an ended and is
actually connected to something else
okay so yeah the criteria let's say you
and your interpret you you give an
interpretation of a narrative in the
Bible if they are an element in the
Bible in a story so how what criteria
can we use to determine if this
interpretation is just some crazy
Association or if it's something that's
valid if it's a valid meaning that's
given to this event in the Bible or this
part of the story so the way I see it is
it's exactly the same as what scientists
use to determine if a scientific
knowledge is valid it's first of all you
have to look at consistency okay so if
somebody says I'm going to use examples
with snake again like I did report and
somebody says the snake is a symbol of I
don't know what do people usually say
well they don't know what they're
talking about it's a symbol of good
fortune and for to something like that
that's exact thats what people usually
the ones they don't put in symbolism
yeah well usually when people don't
really understand symbolism they always
everything's a symbol of fertility for
some reason okay so so that so how do
you know if it's in the tradition that
that is valid well you have to look at
consistency so if you read the rest of
the Bible and then there's other
examples of it snakes right and then
your interpretation of the snakes it's
nowhere except at that particular first
example that you are looking at then you
don't have it you're wrong think again
okay so that
so it's like the same thing in science I
mean if you have a theory about reality
and it only applies to a very specific
phenomenon they keep working and you
don't have anything you're just
describing it you just made up a theory
to describe just that fact you're trying
to have a universal theory that explains
a specific fact so it has to apply to
different examples different phenomena
not just the one so it's the same thing
if you're interpreting a symbol you
don't want it to work on just that Tory
it's ridiculous it has to work all the
time so if you say the snake is a symbol
of fertility then look at all the other
examples of the snakes in the Bible's is
it does it make sense the answer is no
so it's not that so that's one criteria
another one which goes with the first
one really is it has to be comprehensive
so it has to be equal to include a lot
of the stories so if you have a specific
pattern that you use to interpret the
story that pattern you should be able to
use it to interpret a lot of other
stories so if you say for example one of
the most fundamental patterns in in
ancient cosmology is the tree okay the
tree the snake those are usually seen as
opposites so if that's true then you
should finally tree that pattern you
should be able to find it in a whole lot
of other stories all right so if you use
that if you think that pattern is
fundamental then fundamental mean it
explains a whole lot of things so just
like a scientific theory like let's say
there is in relation to gravity you
should be able to explain a lot of
phenomenon with that single theory if
you don't this you're missing some some
point you're missing a simpler truth a
more universal truth so that's that's
the other thing well the other I would
say criteria is does it provide insight
if you have an interpretation of a
symbol and it provides you with zero
insight into the nature of this story
into the facts
follow and the fact that preceded it's
worthless
what's the point so I think you were
talking about that at the beginning you
were saying about interpreting things
horizontally are you talking about that
performance so we target before
conversation okay I can mention that
what is it yet go ahead that we see with
symbolism one of the problem we see with
symbolism is a kind of a augmentation
probably do a video about this but it's
like the conspiracy version of symbolism
where symbolism is interpreted like on
the same level and so an image doesn't
refer to a higher reality or to a more
it's a universal reversal true it only
it's only a code that hides a secret
like a secret meaning of something
someone's trying to hide from you like
the fact that maybe they're aliens or
you know like there's a secret society
that wants to some for some reason they
want they want to hide their
communication but then make it available
for others like that type of symbolism
like who cares about that stuff yeah
that doesn't help you live your life
yeah and what it the funny thing is that
type of symbolism does exist but it's
absolutely secondary I mean if you want
to understand the Bible forget about
that you're not it's not going to help
you to understand anything so yeah but I
have and I see an example of that I
don't remember exactly where but it was
somebody who was trying to interpret the
story of Elijah and he was talking about
the Raven that feeds Elijah and then the
interpretation of the person was well
the Raven actually refers to a secret
society oh my goodness that went and fed
Elijah okay I don't remember where I got
that from bilateral interpretation and
in my in my mind when I saw that I was
thinking to myself that gives no
understanding of the story whatsoever it
doesn't give any more understanding for
stories than to say that it's a raven
not at all so that's an example of a
faulty interpretation it provides you
with no higher understanding of a
specific story yeah so the idea
just like just like a scientific theory
you'll find a scientific theory why is
it valuable because it allows you to
understand a whole bunch of things yeah
that it's the same thing with this
symbolic interpretation you have certain
patterns that are universal and if you
use these patterns to interpret the
story it will reveal the nature of the
story to you it will make it obvious it
will make it clear just like a theory
reveals the nature of reality when it
works when it's right of course has to
be correct if you have a wrong theory
that it doesn't help you at all same
thing with an interpretation if you have
a wrong interpretation it will mislead
you but if you're honest if you're
honest about it you'll see that it
doesn't work you're dishonest or you can
always fool yourself of course anybody
can do that but but that's not this is
one of the reasons why certain people
are against the idea of a symbolic
interpretation is they're worried about
this possibility of interpreting things
however you want them but that problem
is an everyday problem it's not just a
problem of interpreting the Bible things
the problem of having a faulty
interpretation of reality is it is a
problem that everyone's faced with so it
doesn't go away when you all the sudden
you you refuse to do it with a biblical
narrative it's something we do every
single day in everyday life we interpret
reality with a theory if we're wrong
where's a groove it hurts them
it harms us so that that problem doesn't
disappear it's always there so it's
there when you interpret the Bible - is
there we interpret some something that
somebody tells you outside or at your
job and it's always there so there's no
way out of that out of that problem so
one of the one of the craziest ones the
craziest ones that someone wrote me
recently about about that and about this
type of lateral interpretation of
symbolism whereas like every symbol that
you could come up with was basically a
symbol for mushrooms so basically like
drugs
yeah drugs it was all drugs and it's
like
you know that doesn't help like how does
that help you like why would you read a
story that I call a hidden favorite
books that a highs references to drugs
in it like what's the funny thing is how
does anything is the funny
the funny part of that is if that person
has the right understanding of what
intoxication is right then that person
would be able to find places in the
Bible that actually are about
intoxication and understand the deep
meaning of intoxication see so if that
person has a right honest my frame about
understanding a story then is fetish
about intoxication would be it would be
answered in the Bible because
intoxication is part of of the Bible
there's that the story of knowing during
a wine and mhm it's not absurd to say
for example that the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil was a form of
intoxication yeah I mean if you
interpret it like interpret it like that
instead of you and so that's not what
they're doing with their you can say yes
you're right they're saying is that it's
like a hidden veiled it's a hidden
meaning which is to show that that you
know ancient people took mushrooms to to
have to have like spiritual experiences
like that's what the story means it's
like I'm not even though I'm not even
denying that maybe ancient people took
mushrooms that spiritual experiences but
like it does that really think that that
story like that's the point of that
story like that yeah but when it is when
it is it is in Western civilization is
just about someone taking more
realization my goodness I don't think
you're very good at building a
civilization when you're always high on
mushrooms I doubt but it's a funny thing
is that that symbolism is important in
the Bible it is important and that's the
thing when you have a an honest approach
you will find those places with I hope
but not just on it but also a desire to
go to more unitive forms of meaning
instead of not all about being
intoxicated at all not just notice about
the inductive but about act but about
this idea of a veiled availed illusion
to some
like social practice and they're not
talking about it's like it doesn't even
show you the meaning of intoxication
it's just to show you that people used
to take mushrooms and now they're hiding
it from you as yeah the church is hiding
from you that that people used to take
mushrooms because they they're they're
evil and they want don't want you to
know that that's a way to they want to
control spirituality so they're hiding
the fact that people used to take
mushrooms but it's still their kind of
you know lingering in the stories and
it's like it's all about people used to
take mushroom it's like yeah well that
yeah it's a good example the nation it
doesn't even tell you anything about the
nature of taking mushrooms but these
yeah it's a good example of what you
were saying of a horizontal
interpretation you just replace
something repose about something else
it's like symbolism is just a
replacement of one thing by another that
means something else so that's not what
symbolism is the opposite of what
symbolism erection symbolism the idea of
truth and ilysm is to reveal things not
to hide them reveal things that we
usually wouldn't understand easily
because they're too abstract yeah
there's so it's just exactly the same
thing as as an a scientific experiment
you're performing an experiment
it makes the abstract concrete it makes
it real then you can recognize it so
like like the example I was before
dropping the two cannonballs from the
Tower of Galileo well it's an event
which has cosmic meaning cosmic
implications because it reveals the
nature of gravity so the whole point of
that is not to hide it the nature of
gravity to reveal it in an event mm-hmm
so yeah so the idea that symbolism is
like a crypto language or something like
that a cryptic way of talking with
opposites because that's what it ends up
being yes yeah it's completely false
well I think I think that comes from I
think that comes from what I was talking
about before like that something
happened and the late Middle Ages or the
earth during the
Renaissance or there's this split you
know of like the more kind of literal
things and then the higher falutin type
of of spiritualism let's say are called
occultism and all that stuff it seems
like that's part of it like that until
the whole tradition of secret societies
in the West and stuff had they did have
that idea somehow hiding genetic
freemasons have that idea of like hiding
you know the I think I think when they
have that ideas because they've lost the
meaning that's what I think I mean I've
recently read some people talking about
the meaning of Freemason stuff and it
was supposedly written by a freemason
and I was I had I was amazed at how done
was how about what it was saying because
when I looked at their symbolism I
thought it was it makes sense yeah I
thought I was expressing universal truth
but what I looked at the explanation
that the person who wrote the book was
giving was who was supposedly a
freemason in my mind I was saying you
lost your symbolism lost your own
symbolism and now you're trying to
explain it as a cryptic thing but it's
the only reason you're doing that
because you've lost it you don't know
what it is you don't have what it takes
to get to understand it so you're trying
to give it some other meaning that has
nothing to do with with what it is as I
see it anyway no I would say I had the
same experience I I yeah I spoke I spoke
with it two years ago with a 33rd degree
Mason and I was I never met like high
low high ranking Mason before so I was
like I was asking a lot of questions and
they were telling me about some of the
symbolism that they have and I was like
oh that's actually pretty interesting
like they they have like they have like
this uncut stone and cut yet again uncut
wall and cut walnut like wow that's
actually like really traditionally a
traditional symbol but then is like and
then I was trying to get him like to
talk about it and it was like there was
nothing beyond it like it was just to
its go
there's no sense anyways yeah all right
I think that now that we've now that
we've entered like talking about
Freemasonry I think that means it's the
time to finish our conversation
[Music]
all right so I wanna just for the people
watching so we tried Matthew and I we
tried to say things to speak in a way
that's understandable as much as
possible but we're so used to discussing
symbolism together
that it's possible that that maybe
sometimes we're off so I'm asking all
you guys in the comment section to to go
ahead and and ask questions or to tell
us if we're how if our aim is right like
if our if the level that we're aiming at
in in the way we're describing things if
it's at the right level so so hopefully
Matt you will agree to do this again
with me that would be great
I hope I hope he does and like I said I
announced this during Jordan the
interview with Jordan Matthew just she's
finishing a book now it's not totally
finished but he's almost finished a book
about symbolism which really explores
the the structures in a very concise and
very powerful way and so we're we
haven't figured out how we're going to
get that out to people if if we're going
to have it published by someone if we're
going to self-published he's going to
self-published
but just so you know that that's on the
horizon and that it's it's going to
we're going to keep announcing the steps
of that coming towards you so I hope you
all enjoyed this video